who's going to do it gavin newsom's not
going to do it but gavin newsom very
likely
almost certainly is going to be recalled
who's going to run against him well
there's one candidate
who is considering throwing his or her
hat
into the race that would be caitlyn
jenner
caitlyn jenner is reportedly
exploring a run for california governor
as gavin newsom faces this recall
i predicted this might happen some while
ago because
caitlyn jenner is wealthy very well
known
republican could could create an
organization
and loves being on tv so obviously you
know this could happen
what should we think about the
prospective governor caitlyn jenner
this would not be the first time that a
political leader has cross-dressed in
history
this would not be the first time this
actually happened at least one other
time
way back in ancient rome now the
the bad news here is that the political
leader who did that was
nero considered one of the worst rulers
ever in in human history
a nero who reportedly uh slept with his
mother and then murdered his mother
and married a freed slave and
nero himself dressed up like the woman
he was the bride in that
in that particular matrimony
and he was known for his kind of crazy
days-long orgies and rome burned under
his watch and he
he legendarily fiddled while that was
happening so you know we don't
okay we don't want another nero that
would not be good but the question does
become
would caitlyn jenner be better than
gavin newsom
obviously caitlyn jenner would probably
be pretty pretty weak on
the transgender issues but on other
issues he's pretty
pretty right wing at least relative to
california does the buckley rule apply
here should we vote for the most right
viable candidate
if we get newsom you're going to get all
the terrible policies
including all the terrible transgender
policies and with caitlyn jenner i guess
you'll get terrible transgender policies
but you'll get
decent enough other policies politics
sure is a messy business but
it certainly would be interesting to
watch no question about that
and i don't think conservatives should
just totally write this off
because gavin newsom is a bad
governor and we'd have to see if you
know if caitlyn jenner can articulate a
conservative position
i think caitlyn jenner's views on
transgenderism are much more
conservative than the current governor
of arkansas asa hutchinson
so it would be interesting to watch play
out
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video